[Music]
until organizers of Pi data Thank You
Bloomberg for hosting us and special
things for the people who work on open
source software who actually help us do
our job much better and make make it
more fun okay so if you look online
don't look at the printouts today we're
going to talk about Jupiter and you can
read the xkcd thingy okay right um so
we're going to talk today about Jupiter
dashboard and how you can make your
research more fun more interactive so
there's my github account what I do for
a living is I build Python apps I work a
lot in Jupiter when I don't work on
Jupiter by cycle or turn up with PI data
pythons Python dojos apart from tonight
okay excellent all right okay let's make
it a bit of interactive it's a workshop
after all um so how many people work in
using Jupiter okay and who doesn't work
using Jupiter so what do you use sir
Woody's console okay does anyone use
Jupiter with kernel other than pythons
Wow okay let's which which cannot be is
okay excellent so I'm going to talk
later today yes so how you could have
started is not so people people remember
Jupiter is the same thing as I fight and
I fight and ease for Python only well
that's not the case anymore so today
we're going to have a look how to use
Jupiter dashboard it's a it's a project
so initially started by Jupiter
incubator some people who I think used
to work here in Bloomberg worked on
giving the dashboards now it's in the
mainstream repo so we're going to cover
like how do you like if you want to like
not just have it as a playground
notebook if you want to deploy it as a
proper application that other people can
reuse like make it pretty make it
reusable make it look something that you
know other people want to use how can
you do it one of the challenges that
people say like oh you know in Jupiter
notebooks how can I parameterize them
how can i supply arguments into
notebooks how can I make them function
essentially so that's one of the design
decisions I guess but we'll show how to
do that as well can you import a
notebook can you say from booking put
some stuff I keep you every useful
function so that's doable
and obviously interactive widgets and
more interactivity so I'll do the demo
and so my idea of today's workshop is
you know I do a couple of slides
actually cut cut down on quite a few
slides
then if you were able to connect to arm
my laptop running Python kernels and do
what I'm doing sort of with me but on
your own laptops that would be awesome
but let's see if we can set up this tiny
little box okay umm that was you know
quite a show of hands when I asked about
Jupiter so why do pa'dar because by now
I guess most of us work with data in
some sort of like even if you're not a
data scientist
if you are if you do development if you
do research you deal with data small
data big data in any data so you
probably for your development and
research you you use Python and you
probably like tinkering in Jupiter and
why because normally just works it
doesn't crash the often does it it got
tons of extensions I mean I've seen I've
talked to many people who use Jupiter
often like many sort of workflows how
they sort of start with like well you
work in Jupiter and in the video but
then you start sharing notebooks you
start like working in a team so people
start thinking about like what's the
best way of doing that so there is a ton
of extensions to help people and when
you go into Jupiter and if you do like
if you want to display like a panda's
data frame well it's there for you
nicely formatted so you know there is
some integration between popular
packages and Jupiter so those are good
things
yes I mean we know that as well last
year here in PI data we had a evening of
lightning talks and I think it was on
the same evening where we had like I
think it was five solutions for
improving source control for Jupiter
notebooks why because like Jupiter
notebooks contain your code in sort of
JSON format and which is not super easy
to read by eye but also they contain the
output of yourselves and other metadata
so even even if you haven't changed your
code you want to commit to your notebook
- you know github or your source code
repository it complains about a lot of
changes and it's very difficult to do
the merges compare reviews so source
control is a challenge but nevertheless
have a look at last PI date last year's
PI data
I think it's on YouTube so there are
five solutions most
them do very similar thing they strip
out the output and some other attributes
from each cell and so that's what makes
it very clean so you can register that
as a sort of github or get get a hook on
commit and that makes it very clean I
use it it works yes
collaboration is with Jupiter is
difficult because like you're like well
this is what I wanted to show it's like
oh yeah I have this nice Nobu do you
want to have a look and you start
looking at the same URL same notebook
you're connecting to my kernel and you
start like if you start tinkering with
it you so my screen first of all is
going to be messed up and I will get a
message saying do you want to reload so
the notebook is here if you want to
reload it so we start sharing the
environment so that's about you know for
collaboration so we're going to see how
we can improve that okay well some facts
about Jupiter Jupiter is much older
probably than you think so this is the
original so this is a screenshot of the
original gist
I spoke to Fernanda about this one and
he said yes so this all started back in
2001 2001 that's a long time ago okay
right so I keep the I'd keep the
evolution of ipython into Jupiter you
can read about the big split which had
just completed recently there was a
tweet about it
there was heightened um sort of start
with like ipython console then it's like
finance at all why don't we have it why
don't make it interactive in a web
interface so it was ipython notebook and
ipython notebook server then a few years
back it was decided well actually we can
we can run the very clean UI but the
kernels will be completely abstract
so that's how Jupiter started like
aggregation for Julia Python are kind of
and if you if you go like on this github
link last time I checked I counted 87
supported kernels some of them are more
like kind of text only but there are
kernels for obviously Jupiter Python and
our people a lot of people use Python
and our other kernels but there are
kernels like even for C you know for
compiled languages right so today I'm
going to show you our Jupiter dashboards
what is that what is what is it how is
it different from Jupiter its kind of
its kind of the same and it's kind of
it's very similar to Jupiter and it's
kind of the next step if you like you're
working in Jupiter in your notebook and
you want to productionize your notebook
so this is the direction so I'll show
you in a moment but this is how I want
you to see this project it's been in
Jupiter incubator organization against
github organization yeah for quite a
long time and just earlier this year
gradiated to the main stream repo so now
it's like it's as mainstream as Jupiter
ipython core i buy i buy kernels and
similar projects right so it's it's an
environment but it's kind of more secure
and independent visualization of your
notebooks so you can share them easily
I'll show you in a second in a way it's
similar to notebook so because you still
supply your ipython or more children
sorry another book to the Jupiter
dashboard it still works on the same
exactly file the same code the same idea
but it it renders it in a single webpage
and unlike notebook server does not
allow so there are some security
features which are by design like you're
not allowed to if you go into like press
f12
chrome and you you're not allowed to
execute JavaScript so you're not allowed
for the JavaScript to access your kernel
because you can execute arbitrary Python
instructions so that is not allowed
okay um we talked a lot about this let's
do the do the demo
oh let me show like a typical workflow
what's like someone would do I do it
quite often so if I want to go ahead and
tinker with a notebook and I want to
actually make it interactive to help me
visualize the data first I go into
notebook this is just Jupiter
let's see which one shall we peek oh
well yeah okay the classic example I
guess everyone in PI data at some stage
talks about Gapminder right the who who
knows about Gapminder okay I understand
it started with the TED talk right I
could be wrong here but I think gap
might have started as a TED talk is
basically let's put it like it's some
data and we want to be able to play that
data through time so that's what this
notebook does do you do see that still
works right okay so as you can see this
is the same this is the part of the code
I'll make the font bigger in a moment
but just to give you an outline so this
is just people don't know and that is
absolutely not not motivating so there's
some imports I use book a while actually
I use quite a lot of continuum tools so
that's why I'm probably wearing a
contingency shortening like drawing and
continuing people here I'd like to thank
for the contribution to the side right
so this uses a bouquet interactive floor
as you can see and the same cell
and yeah I implemented widget the next
step is quite fun so then I go like okay
level I have all the components now I go
to design mode so the design mode allows
me to take components and like drag them
around so their position in the way I
want if we can connect you to the same
network maybe this is something that we
can learn seeing you doing okay then I
go like now this is like I'm happy with
this notebook and this layout and I go
deployed so this is like a production
Eisenstaedt so I'm happy for this to be
shared with other people I go deploy
that's what's a - particular server it
brings up a kernel so it takes you know
there is some delay when it does
important stuff but look it's a web page
see and it's interactive and it's pretty
responsive okay and it runs Python in
the background so I've done nothing like
apart from a pretty sort of CSS not much
actually HTML they're just the PI data
image there was no there was no web
design works here it was all kind of
drag-and-drop it was all it's all Python
it's all what you see what you get and
in one step you end up with some hand so
that there's just a URL okay maybe we
can see if we can share it with you so
that's just the URL you go to this URL
and you get these web application so
let's say you have some you have some
data you want to visualize and I use
this I use this a lot for various
applications there are people who want
to like oh you know I don't want to be
like knowing how to load a particular
notebook because it's you know setting a
Python environment etc etc so I just
want to have a like web apple or a URL
where I can go and I can slice the data
or I can just leave it on my screen
monitor the data all day long okay so
that's this is like I I will talk about
alternatives but this is just awesome
all right so yes - so what we have here
so we have and we have an interactive
plot here so as I write it's responsive
it doesn't let me make it bigger but I
guess you can see so ever when I hover
my mouse I see tooltips tooltips are
important so that's one thing that I
found so the consumers of this kind of
information they love this kind of
interactivity when they when they can
hover the mouse and actually see the
data so this is something that Matt
Lockley does not offer but was it can be
great for you know static plots I mean
in the pasture produce like
fantastic-looking plots with Matt
Lockley band you know you can go to as
high DPI as you want if you want to
bring them but they kind of they will
lack interactivity at the end of the day
so here I can just go and say well this
is what the the essence of the Gapminder
talk was on the x-axis we have well
first of all what are these blobs these
are countries in particular regions on
the x-axis we have children for women
like total fertility and against like
life expectancy so we want to see how
that changed over years so the data is
from 1965 until 2012 so when I do this
you can clearly see the transition and
you can guess what the so does anyone
want to guess what the like what this
big blob is yeah so that's probably so
when you when you want to inspect your
data you don't have to because otherwise
you will have like a data frame or a
panel
it's not so obvious when you look at the
data as a time series but when you do
this look at the transition and you can
pinpoint the years when for instance
China made that jump but then you can
you can ask questions like well what
else happened many other countries like
what what what what happened to other
regions so this is great for visualizing
okay another classic example board from
bouquet a blocky server also supports
like interactivity similar to this one
this is based on I think it's actually I
haven't checked for db2 movies database
um just as you start the the the
notebook in your dashboards yes it runs
it's a normal mode notebook so it's a
time to so it doesn't catch the late it
just takes time to load the data first
time right so what we get yeah so there
is a whole bunch of interactivity we can
select we have this is the case of a
multi-dimensional data you have some
let's see what dimensions we have I
guess that revenue box office dollars
length of the movie number of reviews
Mary creating tomato meter year and
obviously like the name of the name of
the movie director cost so that's a
pretty sort of big panel of data so we
want to kind of visualize and see if we
can spot anything unusual oh yeah so I
think the colored points are the Oscars
at least one Oscar okay so this this
would be great for
we can confirm that for slicing the data
so basically as I move these sliders but
also on only in this case only when I
relieve this slider the clot updates and
the machinery behind the scene is
actually trivial is it's all Python and
actually what it reference it's a
reference as Jupiter notebook okay okay
one of the great things that I wanted to
show here which I guess is not really
documented but look so not only this
plot shows me like what film it is but
if I do this I can select some points
here on the plot and I've made a call
back to so I interactively select some
points on the top this is great by the
way so this mechanism is great for like
pinpointing outliers so if you have five
outliers is fine but if you have fifty
seven outliers you don't want to be like
copying and pasting like their IDs or
data into into like a data frame so I
just highlighted those outliers and here
we go so those are the those are the
theorem so search so we said how many
Tom Cruise films do we have no Oscars is
that correct
Oh amen eh okay so apparently yeah these
are the search implies that these are
the movie names where with with which
featured Tom Cruise that's incorrect
does that sound about right okay so I
will post the link to the repo that has
these notebooks because these are the
features that are quite interesting so
what happens what happened here is we
have a call back yes so the Kovac is in
JavaScript if the codec is in pure
JavaScript so this was not Python
because we have the front end so routing
in here in the front end in the webpage
we use the mouse to select you know the
points and then that callback sends the
data back to Python which displays which
sends the data back as a table so this
is what happened under the hood and IMDB
it was called okay
that is the meaning to what happened
you
I'm using bouquet plots to display the
data because they give you sort of all
the interactivity
boki plots can get the data from a data
source and data source can be a sort of
static object or it can be like Ajax so
you can populate it on a callback in
most in these examples I use kind of a
static data source but you can
substitute the data so if something
happens you have an event to use
something changes like when you change
the selector right those callbacks
repopulate this data source and the plot
update magic now this is a bit of a
tricky bit so we're saying right okay
not only we do that but when the source
changes we're going to register custom
callback which does it all it does is a
very simple thing so it says like okay
we want to get the indices of selected
sort of X and more like yo selected
objects and send them back using this
line this magic back to the kernel
console logs and kind of enjoy your data
and
[Music]
this part is where we register the
communication with the sort of with the
front end so saying yep so that's going
to be the name of our channel about 42
why not and we when when when there is a
message on this channel this handler is
going to be called so it's a
communication channel on message handle
message simple so that's our stories
like I put some data into a wallet which
is just kind of dictionary think of it
and then based on those indices that we
supply so we what we did we selected a
subset of indices based on that subset
of indices we are yeah we do this crazy
thing so what so log is a data frame the
data frame got log these are the indices
of these are the indices driven by the
selectors so we have a we have a full
data set which is tens of thousands of
movies so then we use our selectors we
select the first subset so that we Wally
dot index and then all of that subsets
we get another subset that was selected
using the mouse
so those are my indices and I returned
most at most 20 of them and what I do is
like data frame to HTML just render it
as a HTML table yeah a whole bunch of
CSS classes to make it look a bit
prettier that's it is like three lines
here three lines two lines here yeah
plus plus the JavaScript magic
oh let's make this interactive any
questions
how would you initial thoughts why do I
need this how do i okay
well yes - so two parts so answer in two
parts
yes when you access the web application
you see only what's the weather so the
front end of the application what it's
exposed to you but like let's say how
the web page was built so the back end
of the application you don't see so if
you like you know if you go onto Twitter
you don't see all the machinery to
generate that web page you see all the
sort of all the Dom objects on the web
page but you don't see the machinery the
same here
the machinery in the
besides the machinery behind this web
page is your Jupiter notebook because
it's a web application so you don't
actually want users to be like going
ahead and changing the you know the code
of your application so it's kind of
hidden the way it's referenced there so
the server the server knows how to find
it and what's beautiful it doesn't even
transform it into a different like
object that's still a notebook so to who
serve this web application it's a very
thin no jazz web server it doesn't do
much it just serves some webpage but all
the rendering have happens on you still
need like a pretty powerful server
sitting somewhere under the desk going
it in a data center doing all the Python
rendering because now I am having just
one request what if I connect all of you
here and I'm just like suddenly I'm
having 50 requests so I have if I have
50 requests to if I have them on my
laptop I have two cores it's going to be
challenging you know so you need to
think about scaling scaling those
applications but to answer your question
is it's like exactly like production
izing any web application some code is
hidden away but is available for you to
edit and deploy the beauty of this is
deployment is super quick I mean
you can say
all right so add a message to show what
it would have why they want to run this
yeah at this point I can leave it there
and then go so this is my deployments of
production so I just made a change but
like as a sort of developer someone who
knows how to access this notebook so you
don't want your consumers to be changing
your notebooks because source control is
important it's uncontrollable like this
is the development environment this is
kind of production like or QA or
research environment that's it is
published
so I just made a change and deployed and
deployed new code so yes I mean if you
come from kind of a software engineering
background you will say like well this
may be desirable maybe less desirable
because like it's so easy to deploy the
production so you don't have you have
literally very few controls but on the
other hand if you use your notebooks for
the purposes that I described like for
analyzing data or for monitoring where
people get used to people get used to so
you you can like bookmark this URL they
open it today they open it next day
they're used to seeing this or similar
screen so I think it's a nice workflow
scalability is possible but I think it's
a little bit challenging so let's like
jump to that I think let's discuss that
right now because like now you've seen
it in action now what what about the
architecture looking for my slides here
we go right so what is your people like
there is any kind of new technology what
are the benefits and what are they text
cost and like variable costs to answer
your question yes the first time
deployment like the set up is is not
super easy but you can you can make you
can streamline it see why because well
we're talking about distributed services
we're talking about you know you have
notebooks over you have the dashboard
server which is a different environment
and we have the the box that hosts the
kernels so you need to make them talk to
each other on that do we have a flip
chart here by any chance because if a
flip chart no I don't think it would
right it looks actually cool to doggie
architecture so this this is kind of the
architecture in this of jongseo to
answer your question so the architecture
is quite and also these kind of multi
it's not multi tier but it's distributed
services or so we have essentially three
pieces that talk to each other so as I
was saying it's a web server so the
trans node yes it's very lightweight it
can run on the Raspberry Pi okay if you
can install node.js Raspberry Pi
notebook server is also lightweight
probably cannot run on the Raspberry Pi
but it's like very low very low spec box
all it needs to be able to do is to run
that that front-end it doesn't it
doesn't even need to have like Python
kernel install there so this is same
this is thin now the beautiful things is
so you have to environment but you need
to make sure that your code executes in
exactly the same Python environment
virtually environment or whatever you
use like Conda so it's not like you
develop some you you import pandas and
numpy in your development then you
deploy it and it says oh I don't have
vamp I installed so actually it's not
possible but I don't have found it
installed on the in the Jupiter so they
have to be absolutely synchronized how
do we achieve that using where is this
guy this so this is a I don't want to
call it gateway because it's actually
notebook to kernel gateway but all it
does it channels your kernel requests to
the same the same box that is capable
like so this should be like as
multi-core box as possible so how many
cores can you think of like what's a
good what's a good CPU for the size of
your company
yeah that would be sufficient because
like even if each Python kernel is going
to take one core I think I think it's
possible to host it so in terms of
scalability unless you implement some
load balancing solution like five
normally disconnect to a single box but
I think there was some discussion I need
to I need to check whether it was on
github or elsewhere about being able to
specify a swarm of boxes like where to
run so because essentially disconnect to
remember so the notebook server after
after the big splits it doesn't know
anything about Python or R or Julia or
any other kernels it just serves you the
notebook okay
and it makes a request to the kernel so
there is some JSON config so that's how
it knows which kernel to connect to and
you also choose the kernel from the
drop-down but essentially I make that
request go through this notebook to
Colonel Gately five letters but that's
pretty important because it's channels
that request to a dedicated box that
executes your code and the same happens
here so when you when you when your look
when you are fantastic thank you so much
when you are in your webpage mode it
loads your notebook and answers like
okay well so which which kernel shall I
execute and it uses kernel gateway to
connect to that
demo light yes
alright so so I'm gonna hit the powerful
we're going to have a powerful book so
for journals going to call it like so
Colonel gateway so that's the powerful
box then you have your notebook server
and you have your dashboards you have
your dashboard so so the typical
workflow is first of all you need to set
up your development and production
environments so these three boxes
they're not send along they know how to
talk to each other so you need to decide
like on ok so which port them am I going
to use for the for this guy then how
these guys going to access this guy and
how these guys going to access this guy
and also so there is two-way
communication here two-way communication
here and one-way communication there so
the difficult workflow is like you go
into your opening and you notebook you
you start like designing your you put a
notebook you start acting you you start
executing your code how do you execute
your code I mean even if you do it today
you you send your instructions from your
cell to your colonel
that's a multi-core kernel in this case
you are able to redirect it even to
another machine so you can send you can
send instructions and receive the
outputs you know through the network
once you are happy with this notebook
and you have dashboards give you the
dashboard enfold as a and B extension on
your in your environment you go and what
I did earlier you publish you publish
your notebook to your dashboard server
and then when you hit that URL what
happens is like that boat says ok yeah
so I have this
I I and B file and B file so I have this
file so I'm going to just execute how to
execute it I loaded cell-by-cell and
send request for execution to the same
box and this box is configured in
exactly the same way as what you were
using during the design phase these
files are hidden away from the front
from from from the user so the user
doesn't see them which is kind of good
because you can either display them in
read-only mode here or not display them
at all because normally uses don't
really care how the how the how the
webpage is presented to them or what
generates that webpage now let's see if
I have another slide on my demo
okay I thought I have a slide somewhere
talking about the deployment now this is
this is the best thing about like think
how you if if any of you come from
software engineering background think
how you normally deploy your code like
java web applications dotnet normally
there is a build process there is some
sometimes fairly complicated deployed
script here is just as simple as copy
your files across so you develop your I
PI notebook here to deploy them so you
have your let's say if you want to run
like Jenkins or if you have a deployment
script what that would do is will take
those files and copy them across as
simple as just a file copy operation I
mean it may not be sort of robot from
the from the time stamping and source
control point of view but it's just as
simple as a file copy alright
okay so I also was let's have a look at
the another couple of examples
alright okay so this is that's not nice
all these are the dangers of lives and
what's what's going on so I still
running okay
so I have a so I promised a few more
things I promised an example of a
notebook that imports another notebook
and is going to be so interactive server
so we'll see if my kernel is actually up
so the idea is this notebook is going to
import from another notebook so workshop
that MQ server that's a notebook in my
workshop folder yeah that's a notebook
okay it doesn't have it doesn't execute
any code which helps because otherwise
you will have to it will execute on
import but I just want to be able to
import this function and this function
and then I will be able to so my D I
will start generating some fake
processes but live and I'll start
sending messages and another notebook
will be capturing those subscribing to
those messages okay let's see if it
works actually
it's live so okay so what happened here
I imported some code from another
notebook it's a hypothetical example but
quite often you want to reuse some code
and sometimes like you're like I don't
want to do cut and paste like into you
know this code into five other notebooks
so there is a way so just be aware it's
documented in this notebook importer
it's a cut and paste from github so this
is not my code how to the import
machinery but it works it just shows the
point that you can you can have some
code in one notebook import it and reuse
it in other notebooks are sort of no
real overhead so what happened here
started in queue service I'll start
sending messages so these are kind of my
tickers this is UTC time okay so that's
UTC time and I'm sending some values and
I think they follow some random random
walk so let's see if we can actually
view that the other guy that can help us
well that box is ready to be configured
as well so several things actually
happen so this notebook is quite
interesting that's the trouble with
notebooks sometimes you have like a
favorite of it's not it's not a lot of
code but it's a fair bit of code so like
I want to show you something and the
actual interesting things are kind of
hidden between the codes so this is
where you specify the ticker and when I
do that oh the plot should react somehow
so I want to subscribe to foo
hit enter come on should be a random
walk okay so that's that's a notebook
that has just become live and again this
is a bouquet plot what happens once
again the callback is very simple it
listens to the rim queue just subscribe
to that and cube message is filtered out
so because the messages come with
different topics it just filters out I
said I want to fool so filters out
messages with full and read the value of
foo and just append that value to
remember that we talked about data
source you play apply to data source
send the update event to the plot like
it's live
and I can I mean it's already deployed
but I can redeploy it again it's the
same code let's see bar works so this is
now a webpage look an interactive I have
not been much time on actually building
this it's consider building something
like that in a sort of web framework
it's fair it's not difficult but you
know you need to sit down and think how
to do it whereas like if you as I said
like if you want to put something on
your side monitor and monitor it like
all day long or just use the data this
is great I mean it's it takes literally
minutes to spin up something like that
now this notebook has another
interesting feature not only its
interactive but I can supply so let's
reload it again so now before it starts
ticking yeah I haven't supplied any
thicker but I can inject external
arguments into it by specifying them in
in the URL and that's something so if
you read a lot of like blogs you can do
it in a in a notebook natively it's not
super easy but it's even more
challenging in the sort of dashboards
because to remember that isolation of
you don't have access from your
JavaScript to your kernel which normally
prevents that thing and if you like
talked even like to core developers this
day saying yeah that that's kind of
difficult it's like nothing not
impossible but next to impossible
difficult nevertheless that's what I did
I just applied I just applied one ticket
so this is the same page I supply the
ticket and this sticker is so we are
getting prices for the fool we can get
bar as well or we can actually put them
side-by-side
okay so who wants to make a better guess
it supports all those hormones but the
thinking like that if I make it through
two no security following automatically
an opportunity on P maybe we can get you
guys to connect to this laptop
okay and once again what will be what
will the network name oh the one that I
just changed if you didn't take another
that's I hope is going to be the same
what's the best thing to do see if I can
disconnect
right
Oh will they be able to see
no I'm seeing four if other people can
connect to my laptop now so it's I was
telling you 1000 yes yes 10 109 10 9
3000 come on
oh yes all right um I don't have an HDMI
cable okay so how can I send this guys
if you want to connect so this box is
called wireless n I was meant to the
name into PI data but I think that was
already a access point registered as PI
data so now if you access Oh fantastic
that would be also mentioned oh it's
just um I'm limited to this cable I can
disconnect this and no there but you
know we'll take some time so I know it
works now so I'd rather is that too long
now that's okay
it's okay I'll figure out this one seems
to be long is enough guy so D so before
let me just send it to is going to be H
1 9 2 1 6 8 10 109 and the port is 3000
1 9 2 1 6 8 10 109 all right
10 109 and then the port is 3,000
okay should be on the flag channel if
you can check right well this is called
bring your own equipment so that's the
books I had for yep
is that long enough no I'll come on this
is a stretch he's coming with a link
okay okay is anyone online is anyone
able to get to that
come on let's okay which one are you
looking at
who was able to connect just wow is that
okay
well this is what I was talking about
having a limited number of course
something how busy these boxes yeah busy
but soon
we're getting connections alright okay
so well that's a light test so we have
quite a few people connecting so
therefore it's quite busy if anyone was
anyone able to actually load the page
let's if it's on the slack channel it's
also on the on the board what we can do
we can also use board support 3010 so
they'll give you the notebooks and the
idea of a workshop would have been you
go into your pen a notebook you say the
copy like you your suffix the copy with
your PI data username and then what we
can do we can open the let's say IMDB
notebook and we can see if we can if
someone can add let's say a button like
widgets is going to be widget double
button that when you click also updates
update see okay so let's do I can use
the same IP address
okay busy okay
can I restored like I did not hold this
like on Amazon for scalability this is
just my to course so what I can do is I
can just restart so that will kick you
out guys and we can start from scratch
okay that any objections all right
okay well
I was the first one to connect so I'm
able to open the notebooks now so let's
let's connect and report thirty ten and
you should be able to see the notebooks
and then if you go into workshop
[Music]
yeah let's open the IMDB one
is anyone age actually able to run it
there is some chapter I guess so alright
okay well is that a good demo of
scalability of how much one can do on a
sort of single CPU it's a decent CPU but
it's pretty busy
that's you know that that's that's why
we have Amazon and ok next time I can
see if I can I can spin it up on a more
scalable infrastructure alright ok dead
camel well ok that was a nice try
all right so that's that that was a demo
of one of the shortcomings of Jupiter
when it comes to collaboration yes it's
fine when you when you work on your own
laptop it's fine it normally works when
you scale like to a small team of people
five maybe even seven I am yet to count
how many connections I had now but it
seems quite a few and the usually the
CPU was quite busy just just serving the
sort of notebook and executing image
we're not executing much so yeah
considerations resources and memory as I
said it's possible to scale up using as
details argh indeed off live right
resources and and memory is possible to
scale up using f5 or similar solutions
what's actually important when you
project like when you know I was like oh
yeah here's a notebook let's make it a
web application well remember it
actually so what the web application
does is it does everything your notebook
does it does all the imports it does all
the executes all the cells so the
runtime is important okay so make sure
that you precast like if you want to
serve your notebook in a kind of second
in a matter of seconds think about in
pre-caching your data to view so that
your data is available when your
notebook starts concurrency well tell me
more about it that was a live demo I
think that was the first time I actually
have done it on my laptop I mean I've
I've done this on a powerful service
with was it 24 cores something like that
obviously yes so 24 cores would have
been able to handle these many requests
much better
this is just two cores and it's not yeah
it's an i-5 okay we seem to be doing
better now if you want to be able to
kind of visualize the data and
essentially have some interactivity like
you have drop-down selector boxes it's a
very popular approach okay there was
just a recent tweet today yesterday just
very recently talking about like yeah I
mean all these things are great but if
people are actually using I buy wages
and I buy we just recently had a face
the other facelift to to the way the
widgets look and now actually i buy
widgets are beautiful the only thing is
they don't work quite well with I'll
talk about compatibility so I buy widget
and Jupiter so a combination of those
two they are pretty cool when it comes
to sort of making your research
interactive these are the contenders
shiny is awesome but does anyone use
shiny
what do you think yeah I mean it has the
same issue it runs like your kernel so
you can you know you can you can kill
your kernels if you connect 20 people
probably it has the same shortcomings
but in terms of actually the number of
lines of code you write to get something
interactive it's amazing I think it's
actually probably superior to Jupiter
because you know most common examples is
just like you know 10 line through 10
lines of code gives you like a
interactive dashboard right yeah now
Bakke server is I should be able to do
the demo well maybe not in the interest
of time but you can you can have a look
at it so bucket server is an alternative
framework it's very shiny like so you
specify what how do you want to slice
your data and the results are displayed
as it has o been H here okay okay
baki server and the results are
interactive so it's great the only thing
is it doesn't use I buy widgets or use
its own custom widgets spy is great it's
very lightweight
inspire you like you write applications
it's kind of a thing similar not similar
to China because spire is in Python it's
not flexible at all what you can do but
in terms of adding like drop-down and
select widgets is great
I have Zeppelin running on my machine if
I have time I can show you
zeppeli is pretty cool if you are
dealing with large data because that
that runs on so it has like spark and
fly spark of scalloped spark and pie
spark kernels and it's a notebook it's a
beautiful notebook it's different from
jupiter notebooks but if you're if
you're working with like sort of biggest
data data that is not likely to fit into
memory and if you have access to like
you know spark infrastructure that is
something worth looking at now not kind
of new things but if you're like how
many people use vim and will not use
anything else right okay so this is kind
of goes into that direction where if
you're like text-only so if you like our
new browser web api now not for me
item and Visual Studio code the people
use like Visual Studio code all right I
think it's great item is also like it
simulator it's a very it's an editor
that is easily extendable now they have
plugins and they have plugins for
Jupiter so you can actually run yourself
in both a atom and so Visual Studio code
and actually see the result and you can
see like data frames and you can see you
can see the output of like matplotlib
and actually Visual Studio this thing
supports even bulky like JavaScript
interactive widgets and you still work
in text on kind of text only yes
you know what I mean but it's more
text-only than the jubilant notebook so
my towel I'll spend some time taking
questions thank you any any questions or
thoughts or do it myself
correct correct yes
similar to I think similar to are too
shiny as well so yeah so if you're
colonel if you if if you write a code in
the way that makes the colonel busy and
if you spin up fifty clients you'll
probably run out of course right the yes
the I was only mentioned yes correct
I only mentioned that the setup the
setup is a little bit tricky I use
docker so I have docker compose and
docker files to spin up the services so
that as few things go wrong during the
live presentation as possible but
essentially what I what I spin up is I
spin up those three
I stood up these three services and
actually they are isolated as far as
doctor is concerned you can happily run
them on the same machine or the same CPU
on the same network so they they can
they can't exist on the same kind of
laptop same environment or they can be
distributed so my example in docker
spins them up as kind of separate
instances talking to isolated on the
network talk talking to each other but
they share essentially CPU of my laptop
but yes the setup I'll post a link to
the github so the setup is fairly tricky
it's not tricky if you just if you're
familiar with docker because you just
bring your dog like doctor recipes you
saw I was I restarted to the services so
it doesn't take long time okay so this
will so kills the existing processes
rebuild so docker compose build I
already have all the images yes dr.
Campos up start the services three
services one two three and one is
running two is running three are running
so in terms of like once you make it
work it's fast and it's kind of
understandable and debuggable
to make it work yes it's a bit
challenging I have to be honest the
challenges the challenging part is
compatibility so there have been
releases of power like Jupiter and
ipython components that are not exactly
compatible with each other
and actually some later versions so if
you so they're currently available as
PIP packages so if you people told them
they would unfold the dependency that
the other package needs so the solution
to that is actually for someone to spend
some time and quantify in conda you can
much easier specify which which
combinations of versions are not
compatible so it will find a subset of
versions which are compatible
with each other using using people in
this case yeah so that that's what
typically happens you install a later
version but it our installs an installed
and installed an earlier version of the
package required by another component
yes absolutely it is it isn't a github
live I just haven't sent a link right um
it's someone put it already great
otherwise I will so there was a doctor
somewhere ok I'll find out there was a
docker folder so yeah good point so
these combinations of versions are known
to work with each other and you know if
you if someone one if anyone wants to
make it improve this infrastructure you
can work on quantifying those packages
because that will make it easier to see
what's compatible what's not
it's the convenience a lot of people a
lot of people are familiar with Jupiter
it's a few things actually convenience
and time to market if you are familiar
with Python Jupiter you can spin up
things very quickly so what
Jupiter dashboards allows you is the
production eyes that's very fast but
otherwise yes there is like otherwise we
just killed my cpu so it was so the same
application would have been written in
much more efficiently as a standalone
web application but it's more effort and
in its special you know special skills
whereas like if you are in the business
of looking at data and manipulating the
data the chances are you're more
familiar with Python in Jupiter than
with a sort of web frameworks so it's
convenience and speed to market yes
yep super sentai I'm not coming their
way
how do you supply the data to it right
yeah I'll definitely I'm not familiar
with that one so I will have a look
Super Saturday yeah yeah so um there are
a lot of alternatives out there has so
right it doesn't scale
correct this reservation so this the
benefit of this is convenience and speed
to market so you don't need kind of
specialist skills to develop something
like that
someone from DevOps can scribble or can
install what's what I have here in
docker for the actual users and the rest
is all Jupiter so it's all familiar to
people all right anyone else all right
well thank you thank you for coming down
[Applause]
[Music]